so let's start at the the core the
conversation which is what the hell is
social money yeah so take you back and
then back again here so the concept of
social currency let's say is around 120
years old right or social capital this
idea that every kind of individual has
this this network around them and that
network has this sort of almost
intangible value we sort of carried this
in like a philosophical sense
so what aetherium uniquely allows you to
do is turn this cultural primitive now
into a digital and financial primitive
so the network value that let's say you
have starting a podcast and sort of you
know a sub stack and having this
presence
the idea is you could effectively make
that fungible and tradable and send able
through aetherium and then for us we see
this really as a mass adoption primitive
in the future we see many people having
their own currencies so we wanted to
create a term that was super friendly
almost as friendly as ice cream to words
that people just like next to each other
and this effectively became social money
so social Mounier branded aetherium
tokens named after individuals and
communities and yeah and so would it be
fair to say that this is analogous to
like Amazon gift cards right where it's
a branded currency that can be used
within that network or is that something
that would be a little bit inaccurate
yeah so so we adopt a lot of language on
roles if you go to role right now
social money can be earned it could be
redeemed but aetherium adds these
amazing benefits I mean first of all
social money now becomes interoperable
across systems right and iam so there's
social money on blockchain platforms
like like you know swap so social
money's traded every day people exchange
it for different entities or collectible
so it sent all the time on on open sea
there's folks that use it on patreon and
twitch and Instagram and Twitter so the
idea of creating this interoperable
all auditable system where the value
could be integrated into different
platforms is really special because all
of a sudden you're not just on the
network you become the network and
philosophically that's why people we
think are coming to role didn't really
have their own money and that's just the
lead-in but philosophically the cell is
once you have your own money you can
create your own rules and become the
network and it's a very new value prop
that we think is unique for the this
decade so help me understand like why do
I let's say if I'm X person running a
community right let's just say it's um I
don't know say whatever community why do
I need my own currency versus just use
whether it's fiat currency or one of the
existing cryptocurrencies yes so fiat
currency is great
for social money we really see this as
complementary so a lot of people that
have an online community effectively a
lot of them really have their own their
own their own culture with fan behavior
they may even have their own language
with gifts and memes what social money
literally does is bring economics to
that digital community or nation the
community now has its own money and its
own sense of belonging and what happens
here is social money really opens up new
feature sets right the community itself
can be traded it could exist on many
platforms while being sort of
independent of all platforms as well and
it's an amazing tool to really start
incentivizing your community right so if
there's something you want to do whether
it's sort of more subscriptions on you
know YouTube or more comments on sub
stack you can literally like a like a
new web superpower generate that type of
activity directly towards directly
towards those actions with your social
money got it
and so I guess part of this is it's less
about the money and it's more about the
social component to branding etc like
the monetary policy if you will is not
the focus it's much more around how do
you use this new exchange of value in a
community to get people to kind of stay
locked in be much more engaged
to participate earn things all that type
of stuff is that fair yeah yeah so we're
onboarding entirely new communities in
this in this sort of completely new way
and you know we've made the economics as
simple as you know Twitter has made you
know character counts right so Twitter
has a 280 character max role is a 10
million unit of social money maximum
supply and so every person that comes on
role doesn't need to do any mental math
or anything like this they'll come on
and know that they have a ten million
supply like at 2 million on day one and
so the rest will be released over time
yeah absolutely you're able to now sort
of send your social money across
platforms have it be spent on different
products and create different ways for
it to be aired so if I wanted to create
let's say a pump coin right and there's
10 million pop coins that exist in the
world do they all hold whatever value I
ascribe to them is there an open market
that determines that value do kind of
the users in my community or network
just ascribe that value how does that
work yes so first if you created pump I
think everyone freaked out in a really
good way you wouldn't be alone that
there's a lot of people of massive
communities that have just joined roll
Fred Wilson's testing it out with ABC we
just talked to ja Rule will sort of be
doing something with him later on and
folks like kami Russo and sort of others
I've met a build size what communities
are on roll as well what's very
interesting is we we basically cloned
the unit swap protocol so we have our
own eunice WAP front-end
which allows any sort of social money to
be traded easily and what we would do
effectively if you wanted to is start
market making pom right so we've done
this enough that we could ascertain the
value of any social money in the
ballpark of you know an order of
magnitude so there's social money now
that's worth half a million dollars is
market cap there's some that's worth a
few hundred thousand so once we once we
sort of do that the market is really
going to tell us the value of pom at
that point and it sort of stays there
and what we've seen is as more utility
is driven to
social money the demand for the network
goes up and that sort of increases the
value of social money so it's this idea
of sort of the community is almost a
form of cash flow and if there's more
demand for the community there's more
demand for your social money what's like
the best way you've seen it used within
a community any examples that you can
talk about in terms of just obviously
when people hear money they think okay
you're paying for something or you're
receiving value for something but how
have you seen this specifically used in
community so you think is pretty cool
yeah so there's there's several examples
so I think one of the most popular ones
that barstool sports heard about this a
few others so there's someone unroll
who's a young entrepreneur and sort of a
community manager named Alex masse mash
and sort of Alex raised $20,000 with his
social money named Alex so he
effectively built all of his rewards on
roll built a network and did a formal
Kickstarter Kickstarter style crowd fund
and used Alex as a crowd funding
mechanism another engineer named Herman
did this as well so Herman raised around
$25,000 that's an extremely interesting
use case it's just kind of building your
own network and monetizing in this new
way aside for the people the people who
bought the the Alex token or the other
one what did they get in return like why
would they buy Alex for example yeah so
buying Alex or Kerman effectively gives
you a stake in that person's network and
so what that means is you now own
basically a percentage of this community
and if you believe in sort of the
success of this community over time what
that could effectively lead to sort of
an overwhelming growth of what the
community means and the interesting
thing is this isn't just tied to Alex or
Kerman it's tied to the currency and
what we've seen over time is the most
successful social money it's utility
actually becomes democratized so
biggest users of Alex and Kerman aren't
exactly those individuals they're people
of the community using in the
peer-to-peer way which which is sort of
fascinating so you own a piece of this
of this community that can exist over
time and effectively increase as the
demand for the network increases